what is spirit doing what are you doing
hello I'm rosalía and I'm here with gq
to present my 10 essentials
[Music]
p if you're
thinking I always have weights because I
don't have much time to train as much as
I'd like so I always have
my feet and you're there what  I put yes
shoulders yes then a bit of triceps of everything
of everything a little to see I am
learning I realize that there is a
lot of technique and fitness is something
to look at because I always have the fitness project
and the weights  It's an essential essential
more essential this is some
very essential tricks tape skills that don't
do it anymore and look be more retro heart that does
n't do it anymore this you get a little like that
boom and it lifts you up this is so that all
my life I also dodge the  They do web
sometimes it's from the back sometimes from skip and
that's how they put this on you firm I
use it daily
this is something that I can't and vice
milla especially this to dance
to go to the gym to go to a pla  n of
at night to go to a plan in the
morning I think it is the essentials are
black and light flesh-colored this is
perfect if you go in a white dress that if you go
in black well perfect and I
usually really like it a lot
wear white and with the number but
a little bit of everything and it works very
well a good piece of advice
the diary that I can't be without a
physical diary as you can see I
use this line a lot and sima I
have the obsession of crossing everything out  If it
hasn't been thrown at it much, it's like
I haven't done it, so let it seem like it
always affects me. It always looks like that.
Thursday you
spend all Friday I have to do
the other thing because the schedules are
usually crazy and that way I see it more clearly
composing I do it more in the notes of the
iphone because this for me is talking
about my life and they compose it is another
instead  this has to  It has to do so much
with the rational with the organized and the
orderly that has nothing to do with the
creativity of the spontaneous so
on the one hand this and creativity on the
other
this has been an
indispensable basic in my life I'm always
cold I don't know why  and always always
don't put it on airplanes and so this is
a basic of mine for
a July and it is always necessary and I
look forward to having it because
I love the design that we did it for
elder sometimes I would like it on the hood
and on top of the helmet sometimes  without a hood and
here a bow it depends is that it depends
headphones headphones to listen to
music I'm always listening to music it
's constant on planes you're always
listening in all arts they fit me
comfortably they're tiny they fit
everywhere so I always listen to
more music than any other with this  thing if anything he
read and listen to music at the same time but
podcast no not so many more read or listen to
music
the eye patches because I am
an obsession  sa der skin which is routine as
I don't sleep enough well I wake up with
my eyes swollen swollen
so I usually put on patches of
these but look, you put them here like this and you
leave them on for a
while well you make a good face then the
truth is that before  photos because it usually
goes very well look
I do it in the morning at night I
put on mysterium and exfoliate my creams
everything but this complaint the longest you
have to be patient and leave a ratillo this
has not worked then I make a real
gum
always the  I love bubblegum-flavored chili peppers
I
would always be eating literally they
would always be eating so it's better to
eat some bubblegum than to be there all the
time without
yawning bubblegum will get you out of trouble bubblegum flavor is
that bubblegum has its flavor then
I like the flavor of strawberry bubble gum
too, all of that, but I like bubble gum a
lot, too, a few bubbles, yes,
why not, but then everything stays with me,
you know how much?  When you blow bubbles, it always
looks terrible on you, so
today not so many, but from time to time
the mobile I spend the day working with
the mobile, it's my work tool,
I actually have everything here if you think about it,
I work with this  all the time and I
die if I lose it the application I
use the most is called the zeta seal it
's like having a walkie talkie and talking to
your friends whatever without
them expecting it will sound on their mobile
what you send them has  For example,
some test
hello what are you going
and so much that spirit is doing
that I'm working man
and
next my sister my sister Piri
comes because she comes a little and if she
comes with me it's something that I without
my skin and well I die  I have lived
with her all my life since I was born she
was in my life and I could not imagine my
life without her she is my best friend
in mayonnaise mayonnaise and I cannot live
without mayonnaise I carry mayonnaise in my
bag like mayonnaise with vegetables
mayonnaise with chicken  or mayonnaise with rice
with everything with all my compa no fries
also mayonnaise for me I don't know
mayonnaise ketchup
and I love it a lot I like it a lot well
these have been my 10 essentials and
I hope you liked them and thanks
for looking at it